normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
The Daily Mail younger Americans fearing
2024 election could spark a civil war
are preparing for a disaster 40% of jenz
have spent money on doomsday
preparations new survey fines and it was
uh 2,179 us adults in January to
February and they found
40% had bought uh prepping supplies and
the majority believe it's because uh uh
there may be civil unrest or Civil War
in the next year I wonder what prepping
supplies counts as because if if they're
just like oh they bought a handgun and
that's prepping supplies I'm a little
leer about whether they're actually
interested in preparing for emergencies
but they're just like wow I don't think
it's that simple I think it's uh it's a
they were asked if they'd spent money
preparing for
emergencies so it's likely going to be
flashlight I change the batteries in my
in my my uh
fire alarm yeah there's so many I got a
I got a life straw we got a bunch of
them yeah we probably have like 50
downstairs I order a machete you know
like I got a knife I got a LIF straw I
got I got extra shoelaces just have to
go hunting buy blowout kits buy TNI kits
and Gauze so it seems like a large
portion are concerned but I do think
that uh the headline is a bit misleading
the reality is 40% of gen Z has spent
money on prep preparing for an emergency
now how many of them are are doing it
because they fear Civil War I don't know
if it's that much that's actually not
stated in the story but I do think the
fact that jenz has actually considered
buying things these are people who claim
to be broke can't afford food can't
afford to buy homes are saying the
Boomers ripped them off and stole all
the wealth and all that stuff but
they're going to spend money preparing
for disasters it says one of two things
one jenzi is as we already mentioned
before more conservative and thinking
long term and that's all it really means
or in their world they are seeing things
that give them reason to believe
emergencies disasters and potential
conflict may be arising in the future
the reason why boomers are probably less
likely to do things like this is because
in their minds Civil War is not possible
but to gen Z Society is already broken I
mean these are these are these are young
people who are teenagers in the first
recession and they're watching all that
happen around them Millennials I imagine
would be in a similar place or pot or or
I wonder if this suggests Pro ction as
to what they think is going to happen in
2024 meaning many genz people not all of
them not necessarily the plurality are
far-left are engaging in acts of
violence every day and so the reason
they believe they need to prepare for
disasters is because they might be the
disaster so so I I think you're spot on
I I think the only way an actual like
open Civil War happens is if Republicans
take back power and then the left starts
doing activity no I don't think so you
think it could be done started by a
right winger I think it will a 99%
chance be started by a right winger I I
I just I don't know I I think that I
just don't see it I I think Mo all of
the talk about right-wing the rightwing
starting a Civil War I just think it's
what what what are the hot Catalyst
issues that could lead to a Civil War in
this country Donald Trump getting
elected in in what way like you the
Democrats you think will go and Target
states and
yeah I think well no I think you'll see
BLM and antifa on steroids I think that
you will have they really do believe
that he is Hitler I mean they have been
brainwashed to believe that he's I think
maybe neolibs do but when Trump got
elected the first time we had a large
riot in DC and that was kind of it and
then it wasn't until uh the summer of
love that things got truly truly bad
it's possible that if Donald Trump won
in 2020 West Coast states would have
seceded from the Union as per that
Boston Globe report which could be the
Catalyst for a Civil War and so that's a
more direct formal however Republicans
are more likely in that regard to just
be like see you later but so what I
actually see is abortion border security
and um and and foreign war I think like
antifa you know maybe would would try
and facilitate some kind of escalation
of conflict they believe they are
because they want to destroy the system
and burn it down but in terms of issues
that are affecting this country that
could lead to someone actually getting
organized and and calling for
conflict I feel like it's more likely to
come from someone on the right meaning
uh we've I've talked about Oklahoma and
Colorado sharing a border where
Oklahoma's permanent has has banned
abortion in all cases and at Colorado
has allowed it up to the point of birth
MH that's the kind of you know oil and
water mixture happening right there on
the border that can result in major
conflict you've also got child sex
changes is it going to be a leftist Who
start who brings a bunch of guns and
opens fire on law enforcement and
government because a child was not able
to get a sex change or is it going to be
a father and a crew of his friends who
get their get armored vehicles drive
into California to rescue a child who is
captur or taken kidnapped by by someone
to give them a sanctuary sex change
operation in the states yeah May and
maybe that is what maybe the left you
know they're passing those laws in
Washington and Minnesota and California
that allow them to the state to kidnap
kids that end up making not even the
state third parties so uh I think I
think it could be Oregon I believe it's
Oregon uh a a random person could bring
a child from anywhere to that state for
a sex change and the state will not go
after that person who
did maybe they're baiting maybe they're
trying to get someone provoked maybe but
my point is the the the left is is
playing this game where it's just the
destruction of the system all around
everyone that when they take
institutions they destroy it they wear
it like a skin suit if it is going to
escalate to a conflict it's already the
left the federal government the Biden
Administration that are targeting and
destroying things if it's going to be
come a civil war it's going to be
because someone on the right did
something I I can kind of I guess I
guess we real quick I guess we can say
it this way the left is already engaged
in the conflict mhm it's not a civil war
because only one side is engaged in
violence yeah if if so you take the
hypothetical that Trump got elected
again and then there were riots again
like there were last time for whatever
reason but last time I was like where's
the National Guard why is it three days
now on the third day I was like what
they haven't stopped these RS so let's
say the National Guard does get called
up this time and then some nihilists in
the crowd that are rioting are like I'm
going to die for this cause they they
want they have fully given up and they
are willing to die they charge a police
officer try and grab his gun get shot
yeah that kind of thing I can see like
crazy disillusion nihilists that maybe
are wearing all black and they just run
at cop like that could then the the
media will be like cops Gunn down and
you're like well gez and then the media
INF Flames I could see like that but my
real concern is the power goes out the
internet goes out and then just dude
show up at your house with weapons and
stuff I I I just I think the most likely
scenario is
essentially that there is some small
little thing uh relatively small and the
government says we've uncovered a plot
and now they start rounding up people I
think it's much I think Democrats in
power is much more nazes right where
aren't going to do what you describe
though I I I well yeah I mean if you're
antifa if you're actually a militant
group uh Trump is not going to start
rounding up leftists no he won't I agree
I agree I agree um but but I think the
Democrats literally already are already
are and they're getting away with it
getting away with right and and there
are January uh six defendants who shut
up an hour after the riot walked up
stairs with no barricades no glass cops
waved people and open the doors and they
were waving Little American flags like
what's going on here and then they were
like now you're an insurrectionist and
they're like huh we just walking down
the street we don't know what's going on
we weren't even near anywhere here an
hour ago doesn't matter those people are
already getting locked up y so the Biden
Administration is already rounding up
innocent Trump supporting
Americans and they're and and they're
being raided every single day so this is
already happening in this country but
it's a one-sided Civil War right which
is why it's it's I would you can say
it's not a civil war MH if people on the
right take up arms and start resisting
not Civil War now it's a civil war yeah
where I think the appropriate path is
Donald Trump is on a path to Victory
we're winning culturally and so the last
thing we want is an escalation of
violence to legitimize the things that
the left is trying to do they want the
conflict because a civil war would allow
them to destroy the Constitution and
then override this country and March in
with boots uh where a lot of regular
people would just get on their knees and
say you know do whatever you want so if
Trump gets in and we actually start
arresting and removing these people and
have trials for them then that's the
victory I think if the culture is like
hateful it doesn't matter whoever gets
in is it's still going to happen if if
it's like 1932 Germany like we have an
opportunity to change people's minds
before they adopt ISM that's where we're
at right now yeah but the right had the
people call the right useless because
they won't even file criminal charges
against criminals the the circumstance
in which Donald Trump takes power and
then starts actually arresting and
Prosecuting and and and like Rachel
matow psychotic statement executing
people is zero absolutely zero Trump did
nothing during the summer of Love riots
he kept tweeting was he was tweeting Law
and Order that's all he was doing well
he so I have a friend who told me he he
was in the administration but he told me
that Trump wanted to do the National
Guard but he was advised not to
because the military wouldn't do it like
they would not follow his orders and
that it would cause an even bigger
crisis to have military leaders then
Trump lost a long time ago no I yeah I'm
not saying but I don't I don't I don't
know if if that sounds a little bit
extreme if you if you instruct the
National Guard be deployed or whatever
because of mass riots they just go stand
on three corners but but look at
Portland right like is or is the Oregon
National Guard actually going to go into
Portland and and bring Law and Order to
that City Donald Trump if that was the
case if if if I was the president and
someone said if you call for law
enforcement to stop these rights they'll
disobey the orders and then it'll create
a constitutional crisis where the
president appears to have no Authority
I'd be like oh I'll get in the TV right
now let's roll let's roll baby let's
make sure everybody in Oregon hears me
say we want the violence in your
neighborhoods to stop and we are asking
law enforcement to uphold the law and
then if they refuse to do it then you
say okay you are you are you are a
lawless State and you are in
Insurrection mhm but they but but it's
it's fair that they wanted Trump to do
this to use the imagery and claim that
Trump was a dictator who was rolling in
tanks and all that stuff that doesn't
matter to me if Trump was unwilling to
shut down the riots out of fear of the
perception and all he was doing was
tweeting Law and Order then he was not
an effective president so I do think
what's likely going to happen is if
Trump gets elected is it just puts a
puts a dam in place the uh the Democrats
have already I mean the Clinton
foundation's gone
I mean they're they're bringing it back
I guess their fingers are their fingers
are crossed but if Trump wins then this
machine is is is is done already with
Kevin McCarthy losing the speakership
that's a billion dollars in IUS that are
just toilet paper so if we keep this up
culturally we're winning if we if and if
politically we take it or even resist to
a great degree it's done I and and I
think what they desperately need is
violence so again back to the point
about Jen Zer is concerned about this
perhaps because of them are progressive
and they know what they are going to do
mhm you know it's kind of like a guy who
buys fire Insurance on his house and
then a day later his house burns down
you're like you were really concerned
about your house burning down yesterday
and then it burned down you know
convenient you asking question hey Jen
zers you're really concerned about an
upcoming disaster is there something
going on in your mind have you been
marching in protests right you get the
point but who knows yeah I wonder from
just that headline that Daily Mail held
line if it's actually conflated if
they're confl these people legitimately
in the things that I am afraid of a
Civil War and I have because of that I
have ordered it or they just like
they're just assuming they were afraid
of a civil war they're phrasing it that
way to get clicks but the reality is 40%
of gen Z prepared for an emergency a
large portion whatever that means it
could be 10% it could be I'd imagine at
least be double digits if you're saying
a large portion or more than that uh
said they feared Civil War thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net